i'm told that during the pandemic you
started selling
inventions oh yes and uh you created
something
uh called shade dana's oh shade of danos
yeah so you know many years ago i
invented some very fun things they're
very rare and very cool and nobody
bought any but i figured you know
if at first you don't uh succeed keep
doing it over and over again
as a definition of sanity so i decided
to sell them once more
okay so you invented something called
shade dana's shade of daniels
diners yeah what explain the name say
dennis they are 50
shades 50 bandanas and 100 sassy
okay oh it's in your little uh [ __ ]
pouch i've saved
what whatever you call that what do you
call that it's the schlongbag
oh schlongbag yeah i'm sorry i was so
crass um this is the final uh this is
the final one so i've sold all of them
but i've been saving this one
this is a one-of-a-kind for you this is
like if you are having the sword of
teddy roosevelt from the battle of san
juan hill
this is what this is that i you know i'm
a big teddy roosevelt fan i i so
this is a combination uh shades and
bandanas shade dana's
look at that watch out oh do you have
what's that what did you say
oh yeah hey hey right i give it to you
yeah this is fantastic i could
you know i've been yeah i'm sporting a
little bandana lately this one i think
it's sassy
this one's very sexy uh look at this oh
look at that oh
so it's oh look it's a bandana and then
and then
oh where's conan o'brien what's a pale
george clooney doing here
how did you enjoy filming the
descendants george
of all his movies you go with the
descendants i don't know why not
of everything he's done the descendants
is what you come up sorry how was
filming the peacemaker in 1997.
hairclean
come up with these references emmy
debbie
it's imdb nobody said that
that looks great oh fantastic then if
you put it on it's like unforgiven
plus er okay you know what uh
you are this you might be on to
something here i agree with it and by
that i mean you're not
oh sarcasm i love this
uh well listen best of luck with shade
dennis thank you very much that works
you also uh sold something called danced
on
sand can you tell us what danced on sand
is yeah dance on sands are grains of
sand that i have danced on for eight
measures of techno music and spread
around peoples with vials so they can
enjoy these grains of magic
so it's sand that you danced on for
eight measures of techno music
okay do i think we brought a clip to
explain this oh yes i have an
advertisement
advertisement what nothing let's show
this
clip uh this is your new product danced
on sand which is available now
yes and action meets a grain set of
sweet intonation
danced on sands by floor every grain is
danced on by flulaborg for at least
eight measures of music
many variety of dances are utilized to
help to make each vial of dance dance
sans
magical dance is like lawnmower nancy
the flippy flopper the rumble shaker
the rumble stillskin the shaky rumper
the who is that the out peep pop
the mule mcdoodle and many more
improve your life and your moods when
you own danced on sans
available only at lulashop.com
uh okay um you could have shown less
examples of dances
but why i know i'm just saying you could
have cut that part in half
conan when you go to baskin hobby do
they say hey home of
maybe two flavors no they don't because
they have like how many
there's at least 20. okay